(upbeat jazzy music)
(audience cheering)
- Alright, let's share
one more great story
before we have to say goodbye.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat jazzy music)
(audience cheering)
Practically every school library has them.
I'm talking about the "Ordinary
People Change the World"
book series from author Brad Meltzer
and illustrator Chris Eliopoulos.
The series covers icons from
Abraham Lincoln to Rosa Parks
and has sold over 7 million copies.
Their latest is "I am Ruth Bader Ginsburg"
profiling the late Supreme Court justice.
It's out now
and it marks the 10th
anniversary of the series.
So on the line right now
to talk about it is author Brad Meltzer.
Give it up for him, y'all!
(audience clapping)
Welcome back to the show, Brad!
- Good to see you. So good to be back.
- So these books we've talked
about, they're so successful.
How does this feel, man?
- It feels like my family
bought a lot of copies,
is what it feels like.
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
The truth is, is it's humbling.
We started this series as you know,
to give our kids better
heroes to look up to,
and it's amazing to watch
now 7 million parents
and kids reading the books.
We're going on a
nationwide tour, 12 cities.
Lynda Carter, who played Wonder
Woman, is gonna be with us
in Virginia.
Temple Grandin is gonna be with us
in Colorado.
(audience clapping)
We're going to Atlanta
and Texas and Florida
- [Kelly] So cool!
- and everywhere in
between, meeting parents
and kids who are determined to
make the world a better place
with a bit more decency in it
because man, that's what we
need right now. Right, Kelly?
- Absolutely.
Well the the latest book
"I am Ruth Bader Ginsburg,"
you actually knew her, right?
- I did.
It's the only hero we've done who I knew
before we did a book on her
and I know her
because her daughter was
actually one of my mentors
when I was in school.
And the other thing that's
crazy is one of her clerks,
when she was a Supreme Court justice,
was one of my best friends.
So at my friend's wedding,
- [Kelly] Huh.
- her witnesses for the
marriage certificate,
to sign the marriage certificate,
were myself and Justice Ginsburg.
And so we're sitting in the room
and she signs the marriage certificate
and there goes Justice
Ginsburg, signs her name
and I look at my friend and I'm like,
do you really need me at this point?
(audience laughing)
- (laughing) Do you really,
Do you really want my
signature? (laughing)
That's amazing!
Alright, so what do you want
kids to take away from this?
- You know, I think that when we think
of Ruth Bader Ginsburg,
we think of this like stately
Supreme Court justice,
but we forget when she was just a girl,
Ruth Bader Ginsburg liked
going roller skating.
She liked climbing trees
and having adventures.
But this was something back then
that girls weren't supposed to do.
It was boys who had the adventures.
It was even the books she used to read.
Boys would go climbing trees
and jumping all over the place
and the girls would
wear pretty pink dresses
and sit there and watch.
- Mhm.
- And it was her mother
who broke that stereotype.
Her mom, when she was a
little girl, used to take her
to the library
and every Friday said, "you
could pick out five books."
And her favorite books were
the books about real heroes.
Amelia Earhart, Harriet Tubman.
And it was those heroes, like her mother,
who taught her that same lesson.
There is absolutely nothing
that a girl can't do.
And I want my daughter
to have that lesson.
(audience clapping)
I want my sons
to have that lesson.
I want everyone and, and
here's the finale of the book.
It says, "Today they
call me a trailblazer.
But the best part of blazing
a trail is leaving tracks.
That means you're not just
doing things for yourself,
you're leaving a path
for others to follow.
Start with one voice and
let it grow into a chorus.
I am Ruth Bader Ginsburg. Create
equality. Create justice."
(audience clapping)
- Absolutely.
Thank you so much, Brad.
We love having you on the
show. Love this new book.
"I am Ruth Bader Ginsburg" is out now
and everyone is going home with a copy!
(audience cheering)
(audience clapping)
- For more information on
where you can meet Brad
and illustrator Chris
Eliopoulos, head to our socials.
Thank you so much, Brad. I'm
liking your post right now.
That's not all.
Our season-long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to celebrate your book series
and the life of Justice Ginsburg.
So what they're gonna do is
they're gonna write a check
for a thousand dollars
to the Women's Suffrage
National Monument Foundation.
(audience cheering)
We know you're a big supporter,
so trying to get that built
in Washington DC right now.
Thank you so much Brad,
and thank you to all our guests this hour.
Jon Cryer, Joe Keery, Danielle Carters,
(drowned out)
It's not changing.